[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا خالد
المصري تعليق التواصلي مع مجلس النواب
الليبي الى حين الغاء قانون انشاء محكمه
دستوريه في مدينه بنغازي
مشاهدينا الكرام من الكفر جنوب شرقي ليبيا
جبريل وحيده
اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا
اهلا وسهلا بك اخي الكريم مرحبا كل
الترحيب ورحمنا وانت ايضا كل ترحيب بضيفي
اجانب المقابل من طرابلس السيد محمد محفوظ
البحث في الشان السياسي والدستوري اهلا بك
ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على تلبيه هذه
الدعوه سيد محمد محفوظ
مرحبا استاذ حكيم مساء الخير لكل مشاهدي
قناتكم مرحبا بكم
على اقرار مجلس النواب الليبي قانون
المحكمه الدستوريه وهل تتفهماني معارضه
المجلس الاعلى للدوله لهذا
القرار ابدا معك اولا سيد محمد محفوظ
والبحث في شان سياسي والدستوري
نعم طبعا في البدايه هذا الامر يجب ان
يناقش من محورين محور القانون من حيث
الشكل ومن حيث الموضوع من حيث الشكل انا
اعتقد اليوم في ظل هذا العبث التشريعي
الذي يمارسه مجلس النواب منذ ان انتخب في
وفي ظل ازمه الشرعيه في ليبيا وفي ظل
حقيقه الغياب قوانين وتشريعات
صوت عليها مجلس النواب تكاد على اصابع
اليد الواحده تشريعات متوافقه ومتلانه مع
الاعلان دستوري وفي ظل غياب دستور وفي ظل
غياب حاله التوافق السياسي في ليبيا انه
يمكن لنا ان نعتقد ان هناك نيه حسنه اليوم
لمجلس النواب في قراره واصداره لهذا
القانون من حيث الموضوع انا اعتقد انه
خبراء القانون
اعضاء الهيئات القضائيه على لسان الجمعيه
الليبيه لاعضاء ليله القضائيه المستشا
الموجودين في المحكمه العليا والمجلس
الاعلى للقضاء والذي سمعتهم سمعت رايهم
شخصيا اكدوا جميعا كميه المسالب وكميه
العيوب القانونيه التي وجدت في هذا
القانون اضافه الى ذلك يعني انا بالامس
استاذ حكيم كنت اشتريت سلسله من الاتصالات
بمجموعه من اعضاء مجلس النواب طالبا منهم
تحصل على نسخه من هذا القانون ليس هناك اي
عضو يحمل نسخه التي تم التصويت عليها
بلدها ان احدهم اكد لي انه سيكون هناك
اصدار للقانون بعد ان تضاف له التعديلات
اي ان التعديلات ستضاف بعد ان كانت عمليه
تصويت كما زعموا قبل يومين ولذلك انا
اعتقد اليوم ان مجلس النواب سيد حكيم بهذه
الخطوه خطوه لا اعتقد انها خطوه يمكن ان
تمر مرور الكرام انا اعتقد ان كان يراد
منها تحصين مجلس النواب من الطعون دستوريه
المرفوعه امام الدار السوريه في المحكمه
العليا هنا في طرابلس والتي يدرك الجميع
ان المحكمه العليا سيكون فيها ظاهرا وبينا
هذه الطعون القضائيه خاصه في القوانين
التي اصدرها مجلس النواب بطريقه غير صحيحه
عن الدوافع او الغايه من وراء اقرار هذا
القانون ولكن استسمحك فنستطلع راي ضيفي في
الجانب المقابل السيد جبريل الوحيد عضو
مجلس النواب الليبي هل تتفهم انت معرضه
المجلس الاعلى للدوله لهذا القرار السيد
المشري لا يعتبر قانون انشاء محكمه
دستوريه من ضمن صلاحيه التشريعيه للبرلمان
سيد جبريل وحيده بل هو شان دستوري في
رسالته كما تابعتها لعقيل صالح حتى تذكر
مشاهدينا الكرام اوضح ان اجراء مجلس
النواب يزعزع الثقه بين مجلس الدوله
والنواب يهدم جهود الوصول الى توافق حول
المسار الدستوري يعمق الانقسام المؤسسي
همم في البلاد كيف تنقل ذلك جبريل الوحيد
من جديد
مرحبا بك اخي الكريم ابو الضيوف وبضيفه
بالمشاهدين الكرام همم دعني اولا ان يعني
اقول ان المحكمه الدستوريه يفترض انها لا
تفعل الا بالدستور كانت لدينا في نظام
المملكه دائره الدستوريه وشهد لها
بالنزاهه افطرت حتى مراسيم ملكيه عطلت هذه
المحكمه الدستوريه فعلت اخيرا يعني في
فتره متاخره من النظام السابق في حدود
معينه لا ترقى الى النظر في الامور
السياسيه همم ضل الامر على هذا الحال بعد
ثوره 17 فبراير همم يعني همم همم فعلت
لفتره واحده فقط ل- بسبب مناكفات سياسيه
معروفه جدا عندما همم عطل يعني همم عندما
حدث انتخابات مجلس النواب ولم ترضى بها
اطراف سياسيه معينه تحت حراب هذه
الميليشيات والمجموعات المسيطره على
العاصمه فعلت هذه الدائره الدستوريه وقفزت
على طعون كثيره همم وبثت فقط في طعن واحد
وهو الذي نظر له ربما بوجه مختلفه انه
ربما يكون قد عطل او الغى مجلس النواب
يعني فيه اراء مختلفه وبينما قفز على اهم
اطاعا وهو طعن همم
في همم
العزل السياسي قانون العزل السياسي المعيب
همم ثم قفلت هذه الدائره من المحكمه
العليا وضلت مقفله وهذا كانت حسنه يعني
لان الان نحن في وضع غير مستقر وضع غير
سياسي لا يوجد لدينا الدستور دائم له
محكمه دستوريه تستطيع ان تستمد منه السلط
القضائيه نحن مع يعني عدم التداخل في شان
القضاء ويجب ان كل شئون القضاء تكون
منبثقه من دستور ولكن بهذا الوضع وهذه
مناكفات وهذا الانقسام السياسي الشديد جدا
همم ان كنا قد ارتحنا لعدم فتح الدائره
الدستوريه لانها ستدخل البلاد في متاهات
لها اول وليس لها اخر الان اخيرا عندما
اشتد هذا همم الخلاف السياسي علمنا ان
المحكمه الدستوريه تتفاعل مره ثانيه
لتستغل مع اطراف معين احنا نعلم ان الذين
قناى ان العاصمه هي اختطفه مسيطر عليها
منها اطراف اجنبيه ومن الاشياء ومن سلطه
امر واقع غير محترفه بالسلطه بمجلس النواب
وفي هذا الاعتراف مجلس النواب تدخل من
واقع همم اختصاصاته باصدار القوانين
باصدار قانون ااه يعني همم ليه محكمه
دستوريه تكون في منعه عن هذا الصراع تكون
بعيده عن خاصيه المختطفه هذا هو ما قام به
مجلس النواب همم
مجلس الدوله لا علاقه له بقوانين التي
يصدرها مجلس النواب علاقت مجلس الدوله
الاستشاري بين قوسين والذي جاء به اتفاق
السياسي الذي لم تنفذ هم بنوده والتي لو
نفذت لما وصلنا الى ما وصلنا اليه الان
وهو بدء الترتيبات الامنيه الذي كان ينص
على خروج كل المليشيات من العاصمه وايضا
خط الطريق اا اتفاق السياسي همم تونس جنيف
الذي نص على اخراج القوات الاجنبيه
والمرتزقه وتحديد وتوحيد المؤسسات كل هذه
الامور يتجاهلها
ويحاول ان يكون غرفه ثانيه وهذا لم يعطيه
لهم الاتفاق السياسي هم غير شركاء في همم
السلطه التشريعيه نعم هو كان هذا هو حتى
عقيل صالح خلال زيارته الاخيره الى
القاهره في كلمته همم عند وصوله اذا همم
ضيفي يعتبر
سيد محمد محفوظ البحث في شان السياسي
سوريا انها خطوه استباقيه مسؤوله لتفادي
الاسوا في
البلاد بث على ذلك ان مجلس النواب يقول ان
القانون الجديد يحقق العداله ولا تاثير له
على المسار الدستوري وعندما يصدر دستور
جديد سترغى كافه القوانين المخالفه لنصوصه
اقرار المحكمه الدستوريه وفق مجلس النواب
وتاكيد لما تضمنته مسوده الدستور همم في
همم بضعه مواد توافق عليها اعضاء لجنه
المسار الدستوري المشكله من مجلس النواب
هو مجلس الدوله ولم يتم الاعتراض عليها من
احد ما يؤكد دائما وفقا المجلس مجلس
النواب رغبه الجميع في انشاء قضاء دستوري
يحمل حقوق والحريات لذلك المجلس يستغرب من
عدم فهم المقصود والهجوم على قانون انشاء
محكمه همم دستوريه وتعاقب ايضا على المذهب
اليه في سيدنا محمد المحفوظ لو سمحت
شوف استاذ حكيم يعني ضيفك الكريم اكد امر
هام جدا وهو متعلق بمساله انه ظرف الزمني
يعني لا يسمح بهذا الكلام يعني هو اعتقد
انه اكد على هذا الامر في البدايه ويحج
يعتقد انها يمكن استخدامها ضد القول بانه
اليوم وقت اصدار محكمه دستوريه يعني اليوم
انا ضد هذا الكلام ضد هذا العام بس المطلق
لكن سارد باحاله من التفصيل على ما ذكر
يعني باعتبار اليوم همم ضيفك يتحدث على
انه هناك اختلالات طبعا بعيدا عن عن قضيه
المحكمه الدستوريه باعتبارها شهر لا يجب
الرد عليها على مساله انه المجلس الاعلى
الدوله كان يجدر به الحديث على
المرتزقه والحديث عن مساله همم الترتيبات
العلميه وغيرها يعني ربما السيد همم
لكن حاضر لا لا لا لا لا في في 10 ثواني
في ضمن هذا الايطار اعتبار سيد حكيم هو
ذكر هذا الكلام فبالتالي يجب علي الرد
يعني اعتقد انه يضيفك حتى ناسي انه مجلس
النواب ومن طلب على لسان وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سر الى بروف من مرتزقه فاجنر
المجيء الى ليبيا وبالتالي ملف المرتزقه
اعتقد انه مشترك فيه الجميع لا يمكن اليوم
الهروب من هذا المازق العمل الاخر يعني
اليوم ما ناس اخر لك ماده وسيخرج ضيفك بعد
عندما يقول يعني همم يحين دوره يقول اننا
قمنا بتعديل هذه الماده الماده 21 استاذ
الحكيم ماذا تقول من هذا القانون المعيب
انه الرقابه القضائيه على جنسيه القوانين
واللاوائح الصادره لعامل السلطه القضائيه
على النحو المبين ولا يجوز للمحكمه
الدستوريه قبول الطعن بعدم دستوريه اي نسق
قانوني موضوع او اجرائي بدعوه مبتدائه الا
من قبل رئيس مجلس النواب او نواب على
الاقل او رئيس الحكومه او 10 وزراء لان
هذا القانون يمنع عن اللي بين التقاضي
امام المحكمه الدستوريه سيصبح القانون
حصرا على مجلس النواب وعلى الحكومه هم
اللذان يعني هم الحكم وعمل الخصم هذه لم
تحدث اطلاقا هذا الماده تحديدا كان هناك
في اجل داخل مجلس النواب انا سالت احد
النواب قلت لك بالامس يعني في اطار هذا
الجدل قلت له يعني في ايطار ذابت هذه
الماده اكد انه تم تعديلها طيب يقول انه
تم تعديلها على ان تكون من 10 نواب فقط
طيف اخر يقول ان فتحناها للجميع الى حد
الان ليس هناك حاله شفافيه من قبل مجلس
النواب في ان يخرج للناس ويخرج الاعلام
الصيغه النهائيه للقانون نحن نعتدنا مجلس
النواب انه مزور سيد حكيم في سنه 2019 في
اغسطس 2019 صوت مجلس النواب على القانون
المنظم لعمل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء
معينه وبصيغه معينه وبثت هذه الجلسه وخرجت
وسائل الاعلام نتفاجا الليبيون او يتفاجئ
ليبيون في شهر نوفمبر من العام الماضي شوف
يعني ثلاث سنوات من عام الماضي يخرج هذا
القانون بصيغه ليست الصيغه التي تمت
التصويت عليها مزوره تزويرا تاما واكد
انذاك رئيس مجلس النواب المكلف السيد فوزي
النويري ومقرر مجلس النواب ومجموعه من
اعضاء السناب انه هذا القانون مزوق وهذا
القانون للاسف شديد تم العمل به والان
المجلس الاعلى للقضاء الموجود اليوم في
طراب امارس مهامه بناء على هذا على هذا
القانون لذلك اليوم حاله الضبابيه تجاه
هذا القانون هذا الوقت الذي يمكن الحديث
عنه انه وقت عبثي في اطار ماذا اليوم
الحديث سيد الحكيم عن مقاربات تجري بين
مجلس النواب والدوله رغم عدم قناعتي بهذه
المقارنه رغم انني متاكد تماما ان ليس بها
هدف الا البقاء في السلطه لا يمكن لنا
اليوم ان نقتنع انه مجلس النواب بهذه
الخطوه نريد تحقيق العداله يريد ان يكون
هناك قضاء دستور عادل لو كان هذا الامر
الصحيح همم يعني في عجاله اليوم يتحججون
بان هذه المواد خرجت بناء على التوافقات
التي تمت في لجنه المسار الدستوريه وهذا
خارج حتى في بيان عقيل الصالح ردا على
بيان مجلس الدوله هذا غير صحيح اطلاقا على
سبيل المثال اللجنه المسار الدستوري اتفقت
ان تكون المحكمه الدستوريه في سبها وليس
في بنغازي وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه هذه
طيب وفي حديثك عن الاساس الدستوري وحتى
يعود اليه حتى تعقب سيد جبريل وحيد عضو
مجلس النواب اللي به كل ما جاء في الاساس
الدستوريه يقول المدافعون عن المجلس
الاعلى للدوله من صلاحيات ممنوحه لسوره
الليبيه المقصود بها هي صوره ال- همم
السلطتين التشريعيه والتنفيذيه التي
ستنتخب وليست اسئله الحاليه القائمه
يعني كنت مخطئا والهدف من هذه الخطوه يقول
منتقد مجلس النواب ومنتقدو عقيله صالح
المستشار عقيله صالح نفسه هو اخضاع هذه
المحكمه الدستوريه لرغبات خاصه وحسابات
سياسيه ضيقه لا تخدم الوطن
وتعطيل الدائره الدستوريه حتى لا تنظر في
الطعون المقدمه همم امامها كيف ترد على
ذلك وكيف تعاقب على ضيفي ايضا سيد جبريل
الوحيد
نحن متفقين على ان الوقت وفي ظل هذه
المناكفات السياسيه وهذا الخلاف السياسي
وهذا همم همم يعني همم الوضع
الهش في ليبيا يفترض ان لا تنظر المحكمه
الدستوريه في هذه القضايا الان لانها لن
تصل نتيجه نحن الان في وضع غير طبيعي نحن
نتمنى ان عقلاء القضاء والمحكمه العليا
انهم ابقوا على هذه المحكمه واستفادوا من
خطهم السابق ويبقوا عليها مغلقه الدائره
الدستوريه الى ان يستقر الوضع ويكون هناك
دستور اما وان فتحت
لاستغلالها من قبل سلطه الامر الواقع على
المسيطره على العاصمه التي يعمل في فيها
القضاء الليبي وقد ولدينا يعني سابقه
حكمهم السابقه الذي يعني وضح يعني عندما
ترى مجلس يعني المؤتمر الوطني السابق يصدر
تعديلات دستوريه
ويخرجها ويصدرها وبعد ذلك يقومون بالطاعن
عليها ليعود الى السلطه عندما لم يتم
انتخابهم اليس هذا عيب كبير السياسه
الليبيه ومع ذلك تنظر في هذه المحكمه
الدستوريه ربما الموضوع الوحيد الذي نظرت
فيه وتركت مواضيع اهم قبل حتى في تربيه
القضايا الليبي لا يجوز لك ان تنظر في
قضيه اقم الا بعد ان تنتهي من القضايا
التي قبلها لدينا قانون العزل السياسي
المعيب لم ينظروا فيه فقط نظره في هذه
القضيه واقفل الدائره اذن القضاء مسيس ففي
هذه الحاله على مجلس النواب المنتخب الذي
يمثل بين ان يستدرك هذا الامر ومن واقع
همم ااا يعني اختصاصاته التشريعيه ان يصدر
همم قانون بانشاء محكمه دستوريه تكون في
معزل عن هذا الصراع السياسي هذا هو القصد
ولكن نصر ونؤكد على ان استقلاليه القضاء
هي الاهم لذلك همم الخطا بدا من تدخل
القذافي السياسه وبذلك انا اعتبر مقاومه
به مجلس النواب وهو رد فعل فقط لان مجلس
النواب يمثل طرف سياسي مهم جدا في ليبيا
يسيطر على اكثر من ثلثين ليبيا وهمم يا
سيد حكيم
سعودي سعودي
العليا
الدوله
الاستشاري علاقته فقط بالقوانين التي لها
علاقه
بالقاعده الدستوريه التي قد يتفق عليها
وقد لا يتفق عليها اما غير ذلك
ولا يعتبر مجلس الدوله استشاري غرفه ثانيه
نعم محكمه دستوريه تكون بمعزا العليا
وهذا ما يرغب فيه البرلمان حتى يعود اليه
السيد محمد محفوظ بديله عن الدائره
الدستوريه في المحكمه العليا همم في همم
طرابلس ستعاقب على مذهب اليه ضيفه ولكن
الاشكال المطروح اليوم ان هذا الخلاف او
هذا الصراع وسمه كما شئ ياتي قبل ايام من
لقاء كان مرتب وكان يعول عليه كثيرون
الحاله الاسماء الليبيه المجلس الاعلى
للدوله شركه استشاري لمجلس النواب في
خطوات مسيريه لحل الازمه في البلاد وفقا
السياسيه بينهما هنا اطرح السؤال
يشعل هذا الخلاف سيره عن جديدا همم في
ليبيا وما مصير العلاقات بين المجلسين
وتداعياتكم لذلك على جهود حل الازمه همم
الليبيه تفضل سيد محفوظ
جبريل يتحدث انه ما جاره ردد فعل عنه ما
حدث من فتح الداير الدستوريه وكانه مزاجا
الدائره الدستوريه المحكمه العليا تحديدا
قبل اشهر قليله مستشار رئيسها عبد الله
بورزهزه عين بقرار من مجلس النواب برفقه
45 مستشار
وقاموا بقسم اليمين هناك في مجلس النواب
وفقرار من مجلس النواب وبالتالي المحكمه
العليا التي يتحدث ويشكك السيد وحيد من
نزاعاتها هي بقرار من مجلس النواب قبل
اشهر قليله يعني هذا هذه كميه التظليل
التي لا اعتقد انه يمكن السماح بها لذلك
اليوم عبد الله ابو رزيزه المستشار رئيس
المحكمه العليا عين بقرار من مجلس النواب
واقسم اليمين امام رئيس مجلس النواب
والمستشارين الموجودين في المحكمه العليا
كذلك ينطبق عليه نفس القول كيف نتنصل بها
بالملاك امر يعني اليوم سيد جبريل يريد ان
يصور للمساعده انه المحكمه العليا هي طرف
خصا في اليوم في العمليه السياسيه عندنا
محسوب على طرف سياسي معين بالتالي نحن
مجلس النواب نمثل طرف سياسي موجود في شرق
ليبيا وطرف عسكري يحق لنا ان نفعل ما
نشائع ردا على هذا الامر هذا عبث المجلس
الاعلى القضاء عين بقانون مجلس النواب
المحكمه العليا عينه بقرار وبقانون عبسي
ايضا من مجلس النواب وبالتالي هذا التنصل
حتى من المؤسسات التي اختارها مجلس النواب
وهذا يؤكد تماما مدى ضعف حجيه الاعضاء
مجلس النواب في تبني طرح قانون محكمه
السوريه يعني تاره يقول لك ان الوقت غير
مناسب وتاره ان يحاول ان يجد مبررات هذا
الفعل الذي لا اعتقد انه يوجد له مبرر
هل صراعا جديدا في وقت تحتاج فيها البلاد
الى تفاهمات همم سيد محفوظ هذا سؤال ايضا
شوف شوف استاذ حكيم انا لا اعتقد حسب يعني
قناعتي انه مجلس النواب والدوله او المشري
وعقيله صالح
اراده التوافق يوما الا على البقاء في
السلطه مزيدا من الوقت اليوم الحديث عن
صفقه سياسيه جديده يرعاها الرجلين في اطار
تغيير السلطه التنفيذيه والمناصب السياديه
وبعد ذلك يكون حديث على الهامش على القائد
الدستوريه اعتقد اننا في اطار صفقه جديده
شبيهه بالصفقات التي شكلت فيما او التي
عقدت فيما سبق اذا كانوا فعلا جدي او اسمح
لي بس حكيم في هذه الثاني اذا كانوا فعلا
علانيه حسنه في الذهاب نحو الانتخابات
الطريق الى ذلك واضح ولكن اعتقد اليوم
انهما يحتاجون بعضهما وحتى في كميه الجدل
اليوم الذي يحدث خلال في اطار المحكمه
السوريه لا اعتقد ان الرجلين ساقان في هذا
الامر وسيحاول المشري وعقيله ان يخرج من
هذا الجدل بطريقه اخرى حتى يمررها صفقتهما
وبالتالي البقاء في السلطه
جبريل احيده ما مصير العلاقات بين
المجلسين وتداعيات الازمه الحاليه على
جهود حاله الازمه همم عامه في ليبيا ضيف
يتحدث حتى تعود اليك سي جبريل احيده عن
تظليل لكن ان ترد على هذه النقطه تحديدا
وعن صفقه سياسي كلمه الختام لك تفضل
المحكمه العليا ونفتخر بذلك والمحكمه
العليا فيها عدد الدوائر نحن نتحدث على
الدائره الدستوريه الدائره الدستوريه الكل
يعلم انه ليس وقتها وهي لم تفتح حتى في
النظام السابق الى 42 سنه لم تتعرض للامور
السياسيه كانت فقط عندما كان الذين دستور
وكانت فاعله الان نحن ليس لدينا الدستور
هي اسمها دائره دستوريه يعني تستمد قوتها
وصلاحيتها من الدستور نحن لدينا اعلان
دستوري الان وهمم هذا العلاج الدستوري
الان وفي هذه الظروف السيئه لا يسمح هذه
الدائره الدستوريه وفتحت فقط لاغراض
السياسيه وقفلت والان تريد ان تفتح مره
ثانيه لاغراض السياسيه هذا ما نريد من
المحكمه العليا ان تنامي بنفسها عنه
لان اهل
المحكمه والمجلس على القضاء واداره
القانون ولم يرده كان عليه من يرد ويعطوا
رايهم في مشروع هذا القانون رد فقط المجلس
الاعلى للقضاء اما فيما يتعلق به الوضع
الان مع مجلس همم الدوله الاستشاري اعتقد
انه الطريق مسدود الان وهم توقفوا عن
الحوار ونحن ايضا همم لان ربما سنعلن توقف
عن الحوار معهم لان نعلم ان لا جدوى من
هذا الحوار نحن نتمنى ان يكون هناك همم
حلول ليبيه حقيقيه بعيده عن التدخلات
الاجنبيه همم خاصه تركيا وبريطانيا
وامريكا في الشان الليبي ومحاوله فرض همم
حلول معينه لا تلبي طموحات الليبيين نحن
الان في صدد ربما كما هناك في طراب السفره
سياسه امر واقع نحن ايضا سنفره في مناطقنا
المحرم سياده امر واقع بانتخابات حقيقيه
رئاسيه وبرلمانيه في هذه المناطق والى همم
يعني همم تطبق ال- ال- البنود الاساسيه
الاتفاق السياسي اليها بدايه هذه
التواصل في هذه المرحله لا يخدم ابدا
المصلحه لاي كانت
الاطراف المتحاور على كنا نشكركم جزيلا
شكرا ستاب عن كتب كل التطورات المشهد همم
الليبي بكل شكر جليل لك من الكفر جنوب
شرقيه ليبيا جبريل الوحيد عضو مجلس النواب
الليبي على تلبيه هذه الدعوه غدا سريعا
سيد جبريل وحيد كل الشكر موصول ايضا لضيفي
في الجانب المقابل على تربيه دعوتنا سيد
محمد محفوظ الباحث في اشياء السياسيه
والدستوري كنتم معنا في فقره وجها لوجه